FAMILY AND MY OWN WELL BEING AND
TRYING TO CARE FOR THE
CONGREGATION AS BEST AS I CAN.
>> I WANT YOU TO EXPLAIN, RABBI,
WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR
EVERYONE TO UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
WEREN'T RESCUED OR FREED, THAT
YOU AND THE THREE OTHERS, TWO
OTHERS AT THE TIME, ACTUALLY
ESCAPED.
>> WELL, WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS
THAT I DON'T SAY THIS TO SCARE
PEOPLE.
WE DON'T TAKE CPR TRAINING
BECAUSE WE ARE EXPECTING SOMEONE
TO FALL DOWN RIGHT IN FRONT OF
US, RIGHT?
YOU TAKE CPR TRAINING IN ORDER
TO BE TRAINED IN ORDER TO KNOW
WHAT TO DO IN CASE THERE IS AN
EMERGENCY.
SO THE COURSES THAT I WAS ABLE
TO TAKE WITH THE FBI, THE SECURE
COMMUNITIES NETWORK,
ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE AND OUR
LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENT,
COLLEYVILLE POLICE DEPARTMENT,
THOSE COURSES, THAT INSTRUCTION
HELPED ME TO UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
NEED TO ACT IN MOMENTS WHERE
YOUR LIFE IS THREATENED.
AND SO THAT -- I WOULD NOT HAVE
HAD THE COURAGE.
I WOULD NOT HAVE HAD THE
KNOW-HOW OF WHAT TO DO WITHOUT
THAT INSTRUCTION.
SO I WANT PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING -- IT
DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU ARE IN A
SYNAGOGUE, IF YOU'RE JEWISH, IF
YOU ARE MUSLIM, IF YOU'RE
CHRISTIAN, IF YOU'RE RELIGIOUS
AT ALL, IT CAN HAPPEN IN A
SHOPPING MALL.
UNFORTUNATELY.
UNFORTUNATELY, THIS IS THE WORLD
THAT WE'RE LIVING IN, AND SO
THAT KIND OF TRAINING, I HOPE
THAT THAT IS NOT OUR REALITY
FOREVER.
BUT RIGHT NOW, UNFORTUNATELY,
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF BECAUSE WE -- IT
SAVED MY LIFE.
IT SAVED OUR LIVES.
T. AND WHAT IS SO SAD IS THAT
NOT JUST YOU, BUT RABBIS ALL
OVER THE UNITED STATES AND
CONGREGANTS HAVE HAD TO TAKE
THOSE KINDS OF SECURITY COURSES
IN RECENT YEARS TO PREPARE, GOD
FORBID, FOR THOSE KINDS OF
SITUATIONS.
WHEN THAT GUNMAN ORDERED YOU TO
GET ON YOUR KNEES, DID YOU THINK
YOU HAD THE TIME -- THE TIME HAD
COME, BASICALLY, HE MIGHT
ACTUALLY PULL THE TRIGGER?
>> WELL, HE -- WHEN HE SAID
THAT, HE WAS BASICALLY YELLING
AT THE NEGOTIATOR, THE FBI
NEGOTIATOR WHO WAS ON THE PHONE,
AND, BUT, YES.
WE WERE COMPLETELY TERRIFIED.
WE KNEW -- I KNEW THAT THERE WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS HAPPENING
OUTSIDE, BUT WE DID NOT KNOW
WHEN OR IF OR HOW MUCH LONGER WE
HAD.
WE WERE VERY MUCH FEARFUL FOR
OUR LIVES.
AND WE WERE LOOKING, AND WE HAD
BEEN LOOKING, FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY.
AND THANK GOD, THANK GOD I WAS
ABLE TO FIND AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ACT, AND WE WERE ABLE TO GET
FREE.
>> SO YOU TOOK THAT CHAIR AND
YOU JUST THREW IT AT HIM, AND
THEN YOU GUYS ESCAPED.
TELL US ABOUT THAT.
>> WELL, SO HE HAD BEEN HOLDING
HIS GUN ALL DAY, AND ACTUALLY I
HAD -- I JUST GOTTEN HIM A
DRINK.
HE WENT FROM YELLING AT THE --
YELLING AT THE NEGOTIATOR.
I THINK THAT HE WAS LOSING -- HE
HAD LOST PATIENCE.
AND SO HE ASKED ME IF WE HAD ANY
JUICE.
SO I WENT TO THE KITCHEN AND GOT
HIM A DRINK IN A GLASS.
AND AS HE WAS DRINKING THE GUN
WAS IN -- WASN'T IN THE BEST
POSITION AND I THOUGHT THIS WAS
OUR BEST CHANCE.
I NEEDED TO MAKE SURE THAT MY --
THE TWO PEOPLE WHO WERE STILL
WITH ME, THAT THEY WERE READY TO
GO.
AND SO I JUST -- THERE WAS A
CHAIR THAT WAS RIGHT IN FRONT OF
ME AND I WAS ABLE TO -- I TOLD
THE GUYS TO GO.
I PICKED IT UP AND I THREW IT AT
HIM WITH ALL THE ADRENALINE,
WITH -- IT WAS ABSOLUTELY
TERRIFYING.
AND I -- I WASN'T SURE IF I WAS